[Music]
hi and welcome to managing multiplayer
game servers my name is Mark mantle and
I'm a developer advocate for Google
cloud for games today I want to talk
about large-scale multiplayer online
games and how Google clouds products can
support these types of workloads for a
player base that spans the world at the
foundational level we have kubernetes
and google kubernetes engine or gke the
combination of having both a managed
platform of gke as well as the
open-source nature of kubernetes means
that we can place our game
infrastructure anywhere in the world the
players show up ensuring a low latency
real-time experience for everyone but
kubernetes is just the beginning another
open source project you may be familiar
with from Google Cloud is agonism a
ghana's is designed as a batteries
included open source dedicated game
server hosting and scaling project built
on top of kubernetes with the
flexibility you need to tailor it to the
needs of your multiplayer game since
going 1.0 is September 2019 Agony's
continues to grow its suite of tools
specifically tailored to running
multiplayer game servers on top of
kubernetes cluster the relatively new
offering in this suite of multiplayer
game hosting tools is Google cloud game
servers which is in public beta right
now agon is is a fantastic project that
excels at Ryan dedicated game servers
within a single crew banana's cluster
cloud game servers is a management layer
that sits on top of a gana is to power
your global multi cluster game server
workloads it provides you with the
ability to connect kubernetes clusters
from Google cloud as well as hybrid and
multi cloud not locking you in to a
single cloud provider it also gives you
a high degree of flexibility and control
since you still have access to your
underlying kubernetes clusters on top of
that powerful features provide
visibility and simplicity and running
scaling and orchestrating your game
servers for your global player base
cloud game servers has several concepts
at its core first a game server cluster
which is a crew banana's cluster that
has a con is installed and is registered
with cloud game servers secondly you
also need a way to logically group
together your game server clusters in a
way that makes sense for the latency
requirements for your game we call this
concept rounds and it gives you the
ability to group clusters as you see fit
for retrieving ready game servers from
across a realm by our multi cluster
games
allocation it can also be used as a
target for all or some of your game
server fleet deployments and updates
finally we have game server
configurations and deployments these are
organized based configurations that are
able to be deployed across some or all
of your clusters around the globe
defining both your fleets of ready game
servers as well as auto scaling
capabilities for example if we had a
project called game X we could split it
across three separate realms such as US
Europe and Japan within each realm we
could have a series of game server
clusters hosted on Google Cloud on-prem
or potentially other clouds as well
finally we would roll out our fleets of
ready game servers across our realms
using game server deployments and
configurations getting started with
cloud game servers is relatively
straightforward
first install a gun is on your krupa
Nettie's clusters and register them with
Google cloud game servers second decide
on how you want to organize your game
server clusters in two realms finally
write and roll out your game server
configurations and deployments to host
and scale your game servers across all
your Oakland A's clusters around the
world let me show you a quick demo of
how easy it is to roll out game server
fleets across four different kubernetes
clusters as you can see here I
previously setup for game server
clusters split between two realms Europe
and the United States to roll out my
global fleet I'm first going to create
my deployment and name it SDK for the
awesome open-source game super tux cut
that we're going to deploy next we will
create a configuration for this
deployment and we'll call it v1
[Music]
if we have a look at the config I pasted
here we can see our configuration for
our cloud game servers fleet will create
two replicas of our supa TOC Scott game
server this may look familiar if you've
used a Gunnar's before we could also
create our order scaling rules at this
point if we so desired the config and
deployment have been created but is not
yet been rolled out to all our clusters
so let's do that I click manage rollout
and then select the conflict I want to
roll out to all my clusters and hit save
let's now look at one of the clusters
we've already connected to and we can
see our game server fleet has been
spread across the clusters and they're
ready to go
[Music]
to recap we saw that we had a previously
configured global multi cluster of ganas
deployment which was already organized
into two realms from there we were able
to use the power of Google cloud game
servers to roll out our dedicated game
servers across our global infrastructure
this is just the tip of the iceberg
of features for Google cloud game
servers there is much more to explore
including multi cluster allocation
aggregated metrics and more if you're
interested in getting started with any
of these projects including Google cloud
game servers the URLs to do so are on
the screen right now
[Music]